hi Chris what do you love about this
well I like the Boston got the best
player in this deal and they got a
player that is not only going to help
them this year but I think motivated to
stay there long term
I mean Kyrie Irving is 25 years old
Gordon Hayward is what 27 years old
I mean they now have the foundation the
core of a team that you know might be
Cleveland this year and certainly is the
heir to Cleveland going forward so I
like this deal I like it for both teams
I don't get me wrong but I like to feel
a little boy football did Boston give up
too much now because at some point you
have to stop protecting all these assets
you know they've had deals kind of fall
apart over the last couple of years
because they couldn't you know come to
some kind of agreement on how many draft
picks they were going to be willing to
give up I know that they've been sitting
on Anthony Davis for a while hoping that
that New Orleans could eventually decide
to trade him after next season but when
opportunity comes around to get a guy
that is you know a top five point guard
in the NBA a guy that's proven he can
make shots in the playoffs be a clutch
player in the playoffs you've got to
jump on it so they gave up a lot but but
let me tell you this dad I don't think
this Nets pick is going to be quite as
good as people think
I think the Nets I don't think they're
bottom five feet next year I think they
might be six or seven but I don't think
they're a bottom five team in the NBA so
if you just given up the six to the
seventh pick I think that's that's a
risk worth taking
oh yeah if it turns out it's it's higher
than the top five and absolutely but if
that ends up being the number one pick
then maybe that changes the grade that
will give this trade I do love the
Phoebe Marvin Begley fans did ask the
people like two weeks ago oh my god how
dare you laughs exactly is this more
likely scenario that LeBron stays or
goes no III think look I think if you
have to bet on anything you're betting
on him leaving after 2018 I don't know
what's going on in camp LeBron right now
but I do know that they're not going to
be waiting until next summer to have a
strategy in mind if you recall when the
Miami super team came together the
genesis of that was the Oh Wade Olympics
I mean they were
discussing it then I wouldn't be
surprised if if LeBron and his people
are talking to some other players and
discussing forming a team somewhere else
you know right now
not waiting for next season so I fear a
betting man you say that LeBron is gonna
walk after this year with the Cavs did
though is that they gave themselves the
best chance to win right now when the
player like Isaiah Thomas and protected
themselves with that pick moving forward
so it's not a bad deal if you had to
trade Kyrie Irving this is as good as
you're gonna get back for the Cavaliers
yeah I like Jake Crowder there I don't
know about the big man I know that
friend for Shella likes him he's a
former number one pick and maybe gives
them a little nastiness in the middle
but I look at he can't he can't defend
anybody I mean he they were like there
were some early guys they're gonna be
open up at Dairy Queen at once' syczyk
was getting beat by in some early game
and it was it was not a good look but
he's not the worst defender in this
trade that would be Kyrie Irving look
guy reads a bad defender but did you see
Isaiah in the playoffs last year I mean
they had to hide Isaiah Thomas all over
the floor I mean the Wizards series was
a debacle for Isaiah because there
really wasn't a spot you could hide him
on with Bradley Beal on the other side
Kyrie Irving's not a great defender but
I don't look at it like Boston just got
significantly worse defense we've got
the straight how do you think Gordon
Hayward feels about this trade I mean I
think you've got to feel pretty good I
mean he didn't have any allegiance to
Isiah I mean Isiah you know partly
recruited him and was was you know I
don't know if he was be really came here
but he was certainly one of them but you
got another great point guard and you
got a guy that's younger and it's not
like these two guys play anything play
that's significantly different I mean
both Kyrie and and Isiah Thomas are bald
dominant point guards and the Brad
Stevens effect here yeah it can't be
discounted Brad is an elite head coach
and he's gonna find doing unique ways I
think to make things work with a Kyrie
court Hayward I know you not only cover
the NBA but you cover boxing and you
have covered every mayweather fights
since 2007 give me his strategy in this
fight coming up this Saturday best
guest:how Mayweather
Conor McGregor well I mean just standing
in the ring is probably going to do it
you know Conor McGregor is not going to
touch him and look this whole glove
thing Dan like the I mean every may with
a fight up covered this guy dictates
what laces you wear on your gloves he
tells you what brand you wearing your
gloves the fact that Mayweather is
completely indifferent to what Conor
McGregor puts on his hands that tells me
everything I need to know about this
fight that tells me that Mayweather
knows that this guy can't dodge up have
you been watching the show time
all-access series like the ones they've
been doing Mayweather in addition to
being the star of it is also the
executive producer there's a reason that
every time you see Mayweather he's
riding on a bike in Miami he's got one
of his strip clubs this is they're
trying to create a reality for people
that says may was it's not taking this
seriously at all and McGregor has a
chance he has no chance there's no need
for a strategy he's gonna go in there
and MacGregor's gonna tire out after a
couple of rounds and Mayweather to stop
him inside a you can't say that he has
no chance he has a chance because he's
getting in the ring with him he has a
chance okay how do you want to do I mean
what Paulie has a bet here my votes to
propose I have a fair bet to propose to
the room Toya Conor McGregor ends the
fight on his feet win or lose but he
does not get knocked out that's the bet
who wants whatever side well Mannix
doesn't he have a wheel of punishment
that he has to face anyway she said this
fight wasn't gonna happen so you've
already you're already getting punished
for that Mannix you want to double down
no I already doubled down if you recall
if you be with but Gregor wins I have to
shave my head does anybody do you want
that bet if anybody will take the bet
but Conor McGregor does not get knocked
out anybody want a piece of that with
Mannix I will take that bet I will take
a look the referees gonna have to stop
this MacGregor's team is a but they're a
bunch of lunatics and McGregor's a
lunatic - he's never gonna quit in this
fight but I think we should get to the
eighth round and Mayweather it's not a
big puncher Dan but he's a very accurate
puncher and when he starts peppering
that under the eye in the nose and he
starts bleeding him up I think the
referee is gonna say enough is enough
this fights over in the 8th seaton do
what a piece of Chris Mannix yeah men ok
I'm in I'll say Conor McGregor does not
get knocked out ok
Mannix you good with that I'm good with
that this is really a tripling down you
know like what else am I gonna lose
you're an eyebrow well we can put that
on the wheel of punishment
now I need to find out where you're
going to be soon after the fight because
I'm gonna - you got to spin the wheel
are you on vacation I am on vacation I
would like to have some kind of rules
here because we're getting dangerously
close to basketball season and TV season
which means I don't think I can shave my
head in early September but I will agree
to doing it in late July or early July
all right well there'll be other things
on the wheel of punishment you may lose
an eyebrow though for the upcoming NBA
season awesome that's that's great thank
you Chris enjoy the fight all right Dan
that's a Chris Mannix Yahoo Sports the
vertical NBA analyst and host of the
Chris Mannix Ana show on NBC sports
radio the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
I forgot that